e
good morning everybody uh we have a work
session here and time is
valuable and so we we need to get on so
if we could find our seats we can get
going with this uh you'll also notice
that uh I had put together just a very
short packet today and everybody should
have this it's some information on there
which might help us with some factual
information of where we are on terms
with certain IEPs uh it it also looks at
some information that very narrowly
Scopes some of the the issues associated
with um special education Aid and um the
other material is kind of U just there
for you your
interest so I'd like to get going on
this and I'd like to keep this is the
first time we've had a workshop dealing
with special education in terms of two
areas the differentiate Aid component
and the special education Aid component
which is we previously probably unwisely
still call catastrophic Aid and because
it causes a lot of
confusion uh I'm interested in in
dealing with some of the issues of where
we're really growing
uh how we get a hold of information
relative to costing which is of the uh
special education Aid in terms of
specific District
costs um and and and costs relative to
the state costs relative to the local
and the that ratio and is it is it
similar throughout uh these districts we
don't have that information and but it's
worthy of our discussion the account
ability
for how we I know how we identify and I
don't want to get into the idea how
we're required to do it I'm concerned
primarily who's delivering these
Services is it coming from the SAU level
is coming internally within District to
this District Contracting Services I
know that's a local decision but the
costs go up in in certain formulas and
so and if you have questions what we're
going to do is when we record our
discussion here
uh representative Brown is going to be
underlining questions which come out of
the discussion which we'll put on a
master sheet and pass that out to
everybody so we can get that information
either from the Department or elsewhere
uh before we have to be making some of
these decisions on all these bills which
we have and there's more bills
addressing this through the a
comprehensive look at our whole funding
picture of education then these just
four that we're going to be disc
discussing today so the the the
discussion today can be broader than
just you know specifically to that bill
it's our discussion today is
to special education as we cost out
these services and how they relate to
the policies that are are between them
there's also some confusion I know
between where's cat special education
Aid starting stop and where's
differentiate what was the purpose of
that there is a specific purpose for
differentiated Aid and if somebody has
that we can answer that one so I'd like
to open it up to discussion right now um
maybe the first one I'm going to and
Brian I'm glad to see you here um and
and I see the director back there in the
far left corner behind Becky
Wilson um catastrophic Aid I know is
going to be uh special education Aid
excuse me it's going to be a a a a heady
topic here for us we see that it's
costing
a lot of funds and we also see the
districts are not coming being
reimbursed at what their actuals are is
at a prated amount and it's the amount
that we have to cough up is more than
what we
appropriated and so Becky could you come
forward please and Brian why don't you
to sit down you know together I maybe we
ought to pull up two other chairs other
yeah I
know
okay
okay so uh maybe I'll start it out on on
the sheets which we've had here folks uh
the first sheet is this sheet right here
with the IEP
categories is there are you've seen this
of course do you need a copy of it um if
you're going to ask specific questions
about some of the numbers I might need a
copy but I know what the we do the sheet
every year so know what it is so is
there an extra one around over there um
maybe a lighter question which we could
ask right now we see some categories
which are growing uh more so than in
previous years and
growing even more so back prior to covid
and in relation to the total population
which we have our enrollment which is
decreasing since those early years so
there's our en going down but those
categories on on a relationship to the
total are
increasing do you have some answers for
us in terms of why they're
increasing uh thank you for the question
chairman lad um just for the record I'm
Becky fad I'm the state director special
ed if you haven't met me oh here is that
better yeah okay um so I think that the
categories have not changed in a a very
long time as you can see was um a
discontinuation of the the category for
Deaf deafness um it's now deaf in heart
of hearing but autism has definitely
increased I think it's more and that it
is increased in general um there's more
identification in for even students
without disabilities there's more
identification of autism um the other
category is developmental delay
developmental delay is for students that
are um under the age of 10 so it only
goes up to 10 and it may be students
that um you're not quite sure what their
disability is they have a lot of
different things going on and so they
sometimes will choose developmental
delay and then um once they get to 10
they've had time to work with the child
they had have had time to do things with
the child so then they have to pick one
of the other categories so that is um
that is I I would say the developmental
delay is indicative of younger students
being identified more more ear more
early sorry bad English early in the
morning um earlier on um
the other ones it it diff it varies um I
think that you may have found that some
of the students who were identified
speech and language are now identified
as autistic because they had pragmatic
difficulties or they had other issues
that might have fallen under that
category I think it's kind of shifted in
how people look at the definition how
people understand um disabilities how
they look how they put it together and
then make those diagnoses so I think
that's why you don't see a shift in the
total number but you shift in the way
people um as we learned more about these
different disabilities a different
understanding of what those disabilities
may
be rep Luna thanks very much Mr chair
and thanks very much for uh for joining
us this morning so so um this is
probably the first time I've seen this
this chart it's very very interesting
and and when I when I look at it it um
it also it covers the years 2007 through
2019 when I when I served on the
hopkington school board and um and as as
I sort of move towards the right on um
you know into the into the different
columns you can you can see how um how
the um the number of like autism or or
developmental delay um diagnosis have
have grown over the years and then the
um in the specific learning disability
that has uh decreased generally speaking
um over the years have have
what what have what have been I guess
been the the have there been changes in
diagnostic um uh capability that has
allowed I I guess practitioners to to
become more specific in terms of their
so for autism I definitely think that
would be I I'm I'm just speaking
hypothetically because I don't have yeah
um but I would say that definitely that
is um why there's an increase in in the
autism it's a more understanding of that
disability more understanding of the
different pieces that might be part of
that disability um and being a and um
being able to narrow it down to yes they
might have a speech issue but it's
really not because of a speech
disability it's because of their autism
or um so I think that the autism is
definitely something that has become
more understood in the last you know 23
years according to this document um okay
and then a followup Mr chair so um and I
don't know how do you want to do you
want to work do the work session
is you know sort of locked down the way
we do hearings or more free form yeah I
want to I want to flow over this I don't
want somebody grabbing the whole
conversation but uh uh this is a work
session and in the past I've had work
sessions where we've been able to just
you know ask these questions and I like
to recognize those no absolutely so so
so uh so Becky where where somebody back
in in um let's say 2002 was was maybe
diagnosed or or I don't know if
diagnosed is the right term but but
identified as having a a specific
learning disability so in the sld
2022 a a a student you know maybe from
that category maybe from a different
category but was was was then um more
more accurately diagnosed in the autism
uh or developmental delay category or
one the other categories but would that
change how the students IEP um plan
um would would would be no um it it
really wouldn't um it might it might
give them more information as to how to
support that student within with the
within the school but really the IEP is
developed individually for each child
and so so whatever evaluations they've
done they're taking those those areas of
need and those strengths and putting it
into the IEP so regardless of the
definition I mean it does give the
practitioner more information about the
disability and may provide them with
more ways to support those students but
it's it's not going to change the IEP
because the IEP is built off this off of
the student's needs this child needs XYZ
and how are we going to provide XYZ to
this child okay so shifting column
shifts over time don't really change the
the the the services provided through
through schools I mean they may
understanding the disability it may even
provide them with more because they
understand more what the child may need
um you know if you're sld you may not
get speech and you may not get some of
the other pieces whereas you fall under
the autism category you might they might
be like oh we know that with this
disability you may need more but it all
falls back but it all falls back to
those need no but that's really what my
what my point was that so it could
change the the CH it could change
slightly yes okay that's really all I
was tring the the development delay has
jumped
significantly uh from when I came on
board here about 210,000 kids now we're
down to you know how many kids we have
in you know let's say 160,000 kids
that's a significant drop and I look at
the costs or the number of kids that are
qualifying on DD and then where they are
right now are we
identifying early early early on now for
those that are 10 years and younger um
is it necessary to intervene is that a
maturation issue that's going to by the
third grade it's going to be better
um what's going on here because that's
obviously in a significant
cost um I think that that it's it's it
go I would attribute that to that shift
um they're not picking a specific
disability some of the younger kids they
have a lot of things going on they have
a lot of different difficulties and it
may be well we think they might be
speech or they might be here and they're
showing difficulties here and so this is
a it's a broader term to be able to say
we're going to provide them with
supports and I would I I mean and then
this is all hypothetical I would say
that the SL dropping may have may be
because the DD increased because some
many of those students are going to then
be identified as a specific learning
disability but they could also go to
other categories like I think it it's a
just I really don't think that it's a
change
in because the numbers are pretty static
I it's just a change in understanding
the disabilities and where we are
putting students as their
identified is it the kids are changing
or is it that when we're trying to
identif ify we're identifying more or
it's what we've been told to do by our
training our background
um is is this change supported
by solid research so are I'm just trying
to find out it's it's a cost our our
numbers now at the other side there are
32,000 kids in this program and back in
we're starting up at 30,000 with a whole
lot more enrolled kids yeah what's
causing this this number has
changed um I would I do not have any
data that tells me why it has changed I
can tell you that we are are yes they
are identifying more students I think it
goes back to understanding more about
different disabilities um under
identifying students earlier on than we
than we had been but I don't have any
unfortunately repent McGuire and then
thank you Mr chairman um you mentioned
uh the total number of students has
declined over this period how much how
many students were there in alog
together in 2000 versus recently um I
only have the numbers no this is the
number of of students with disabilities
disability I mean all of them right I
don't have that number I don't know if I
can try and pull yes I can try and pull
it up real quick for
you okay thank you and um May follow up
yeah so there are three category three
of these big categories that have
increased autism uh developmental delay
and other and then there are three kind
of big categories that have declined um
emotional
disturbance um looks like uh SD what's
that specific learning and um speech
speech and language impairment so is it
possible that just the methods of of
diagnosing have kind of moved somebody
used to be in speech impairment is now
uh you know developmental delay or
something like that yes so other health
impaired um I I can speak to that one
other health impaired encompassed any
diagnosis that you might have gotten
from a medical doctor so it could be
ADHD it could have been um anxiety it
could have been some of those students
that we now identify as um having autism
so it that that one is all encompassing
so it could have moved because so that
category could easily have moved into a
more specific diagnosis because it's a
very broad category got um and as I said
the other ones it could be a shift in in
how we look at the definitions of and
how people interpret the definitions of
each disability thank you y
representative pich and representative
Damon is next thank you Mr chair and
again thank you for being here and uh
helping us in this work you were just
saying earlier that uh the department
does not have any data on the reasons
for the shifts in numbers and frankly
the right side column seems to be quite
static but when considered across the
you know drop in overall student
population it does represent a
significant percentage increase
so given all this I understand that you
don't have the data today do you think
the department should try to get some
insight into what is driving this to
better inform policy and if so what kind
of you know guidance do you need from us
as legislators to do it because I
remember that you guys can only gather
data that we ask you to gather so if you
feel that there is data that could
inform the policy please let us know and
we'll be happy to tell you to gather it
to give you the authority to do so but
what are your thoughts on this I'm just
again we need better data right
absolutely thank you for the question um
that is definitely on our um long list
of things that we need to do um I will
tell you that we um currently recently
hired a new um a new data manager for
our office and so that should be helping
us with doing some of these data pieces
that we have not been able to do um in
the past but it is something that we
want to do and that we are planning to
put into into practice we have all of
the data it's just we haven't had
somebody who can analyze it and do that
until until next
Friday no can we represent Damon is is
Mr chair thank you for being here to
help
us so are these
categories um standard categories maybe
from federal are they the same across
all states so the only two that um are
different to New Hampshire is that
states do not have to do devel
developmental delay they can choose not
to do that um but they do have to Define
it if they do it and then we also have
um
um acquired brain injury that falls
under traumatic brain injury so um we
did while it all falls under this TBI
category we do have the two pieces in
there where we say that it could be a
traumatic brain injury or an acquired
brain injury but but all of these are
allowed by federal language and all of
these are def defined by federal
language except for acquired brain
injury so and following up on
representative Luna's remarks a moment
ago and your helpful explanation of
other health impairment that that's
medical
diagnosis how are children children
recognized as belonging in one of these
categories what's the sure
identification process so there's a
there is a um criteria for assessments
that you must do for each of these
evaluations I I'll take specific
learning disability for an example so
for that category you would need to do
an academic assessment you need to do an
intellectual assessment you need to per
uh perform an observation of the child
within the class and you need to do a
hearing hearing and vision screening to
rule those out as possible um issues
with the student so in order to
qualify in that category those are the
assessments and then each of these
categories has similar requirements to
be able to determine if they um if they
fall into one of these categories one
last short very
short so do all children have some form
of screening or if not what initiates
them going through the process you just
described and thank you so they are
required to go through the eligibility
process so they're required to have an
evaluation and required to have those
assessments that I just mentioned for to
be in special
education representative
fellows just can you give me a little
more um description of what
um special learning disability is a
specific learning disability is that um
like dyslexia and it could be that
there's a re reading disability it could
be a math disability it could fall into
any of those categories where they they
have some difficulty with their their
ability to learn and so we would assist
they would be assisted that way
typically reading our math is is where
we find those yes y just to follow up on
um the question for representative
Maguire sure thank you yeah I just
looked back at 2000 where this chart
starts in 2023 so 2023 I looked at
public enrollments it was about 167,000
back in 2000 it was chairman lad
mentioned about 210,000 so I quickly did
the math about a 25 or 24% decrease from
2000 to 2023 in terms of public
enrollment just to give perspective on
that
so so I'll go down to the the end here
and then flop back and forth here thank
you um just to follow up on
representative Damon's question um what
triggers that process so the assessment
process for a student so um anybody can
refer a child for special education so
it could be that their parent refers
them it could be the classroom teacher
refers them um the doctor could say you
want to go in and refer your child and
then um once the referral you could come
in and say my child needs help and and
that would be a referral um and within
15 days of that referral the district
must have a meeting to um disposition
the referral to either say yes we see
what you're what you're saying we're
going to evaluate the child or no we
don't think that there's enough
information to be able to evaluate the
child and we have services within the
school that we can that are not special
ed that we can provide to the child so
it goes through the a whole referral
process and everything has a timeline
once once that happens there's a
okay you see that was there we're here
uh represent copal thank you Mr chairman
uh thanks for taking my question so um
the numbers that jump off the page
really are the the First Column autism
and um understanding that autism is
recognized as a spectrum and
understanding that people along
different points of that Spectrum have
very very different needs um do we have
any data that would sort of shed light
on the distribution along that spectrum
and potentially even the change in
distribution along that Spectrum over
time and some of that obviously may be
um some of that may be related to
propensity to to identify that as autism
spectrum disorder but I'm just curious
whether we have any of that data so that
would not be data that we would collect
um the only data that might be in um our
system the new the uh special education
information system might be the results
of the evaluation one those evaluations
for that child um they might have put in
that there was a doctor note that said
XYZ but we don't have anything that
would distinguish um the different and
you're right it is a broad broad
spectrum um but we don't have anything
that would identify where they are in
that
Spectrum follow up yes um so is there is
there any quantitative element of that
evaluation that could help shed light on
that if it were uh collected and and
collated for autism probably not um I
I'm trying to remember exactly but I
believe for autism it's a doctor a note
from your U medical provider and then um
an academic evaluation and I know
there's and I think it's adaptive
Behavior I just can't remember off the
top of my head um so there wouldn't be
anything that would give us that
qualitative information you're looking
for sorry uh going across no there were
some hands
up representa Ames and then repres
Burton and then we'll come
back thank you um so in any given year
when I look at this chart going
across for the through the multiple
categories that are there um one child
is only going to show up in one of those
categories is that right correct this is
so a child may have more than one um
identified disability but this is their
primary disability this is the first one
that's listed so you could have a child
that has multiple disabilities and then
their secondary could be speech and
language but on this chart we've only
done their their primary one so you
would only have them on here once well
when I think about I've had some
experience with this as appointed
councel for seriously disabled
children and um and my time started back
in the early time of these numbers um
and an autistic child um at that time
that I was involved in would have had
five or six of these disabilities to the
right and I'm wondering how the primary
disability is picked out of the crowd so
to speak as and identified as the
primary disability sure thank you for
the question um that would be the
determination of the IEP team or the the
um eligibility team they would review
the evaluations in that meeting and then
based on the needs and strengths of the
child they would determine which one is
more pervasive for each child so they
may say that because of these
evaluations or what we found we we
determined that um your primary
disability is specific learning
disability um so it's based off of those
evaluations and and that IEP team makes
that determination just a followup uh is
that a box that they check off the team
checks off um kind of primary disability
so when you put it into the system you
have a drop down it says primary
disability and then you have a drop down
and you put it in in there so it's kind
of a box there's there's more to it
though that's a lead into to where it's
a great lead in when they have five or
six disabilities here IEP categories or
that be start dropping down into the
special education Aid now how does this
relate to catastrophic Aid and then the
cost who were those so yeah we we'll get
to that because we're GNA cat AIDS
coming up but let's I might just comment
on that my guess is that uh the mere
fact that somebody let's say has an
autistic ID does not correlate with any
particular cost because you got a high
level fun high functioning individual
who may not have any of the other
disabilities but is identified over here
and another one who has every disability
you could think of um and is very high
cost and the service are greater exactly
uh who was the next one was it represent
Burton
next yes go go ahead yes
yes thank you Mr chairman is this is
this being
recorded okay I some personal
information I won't want to divulge on
uh on camera um I was the chairman of
the Community College Consortium on
autism and
individual disabilities nationally uh
because the students with autism were
showing up at community colleges all
over the country and we needed to do
something about it there was a hearing
in Washington called by Senator har uh
Harkin of Iowa and they had the Surgeon
General of the United States ask asked
the question what is autism he didn't
know but they know it when they see it
uh I work with Dr
uh
um from wethy Dr Dan Rosen
who was the former president of of
children's
hospital he's the formost expert on
autism because my faculty at Northshore
Community College were having a very
hard time with students with
autism and he told me it comes in many
flavors but you know it when you see it
because they tend to be asocial uh they
tend to have no
empathy uh they random range from
Aspergers to non functioning people some
are not athletic some are it it is a
broad category as a representative said
but we did a we did two days of training
for our faculty because they were
showing up in great numbers in in
classrooms and so it it's not your fault
that you don't know what it is but you
probably know it when you see it and um
there are tests and we use some of them
where students were given to do diet
Rams and and he showed me the ones from
the autistic students and the ones that
weren't and and you could tell tell the
difference thank you thank you let's go
over to representa spillsbury
now thank you so I find this census um
very interesting and I think it's
intriguing that there's been a lot of
reclassification and that seems
according to what you said to account
for the primary uh declines and
increases in individual categories
what I'm wondering is in respect to the
topic this committee has to decide and
that is how to uh provide State
assistance to the districts for the cost
of of handling a special
education we we have at least one
formulation in front of us that suggests
categorization based on time in
classroom or time out of
District does this kind of
categorization or some maybe somewhat
simplified version of
it offer us any kind of a reasonable way
of uh assigning tiers of cost or is
there so much variation say within
individual autism cases or or you know
the needs that there's not a sufficient
correlation to make that generalization
and to assign cost to it in any reliable
way is useful or not thank you for the
question um this was actually a question
representative lad asked me I think two
years ago and um it it is hard it would
be hard to use this to determine Aid
because as we said about autism there is
a broad spectrum but there's also a
broad spectrum of students with speech
um speech impairments they may only need
a session a week whereas other people
are are learning to speak so it's it's
hard to go by a disability because all
of these disabilities have a broad
spectrum from very mild to more severe
so it would be harder to do it with
these categories so you're confirming
what I suspected um we're trying we need
to find a way to make a correlation to
cost and service intensity and this
doesn't get us there
yeah that's a good thought to keep
too uh representa
fellows thank you so I have the first
question is really easy um you said that
what we see on this sheet is their
primary uh diagnosis but in the data
that you collect do you also have a
second you know the other second and and
the bigger part of your question is when
the data you collect does it tell us
anything in terms of services that are
required by the IEP and do those have
standard kind of category
thank you for the question so um for the
first question yes so we have um I I'll
go back just a little because it will
help answer your question work
thoroughly we have a New Hampshire
special education information system and
each district is required to put every
one of these 32,000 students into that
system and within that system um there
are certain pieces they're not required
to use it for their IEP but but all but
six districts do use it for their IEP
and then the other six districts have
data points that they must put in there
so disabil all of them have to have the
disabilities in there so whether it's
primary secondary or um tertiary they
would have those disabilities in there
and then they have to have the services
page which provides those services that
are provided to them so whether it's
specially designed instruction speech OT
PT it would have all of those on the
services page so you would see how many
services there are it also tells you if
they're in a placement so if they're in
a separate school or they're in a
residential placement it would also tell
you that those are all required pieces
within that system that they must report
to us
so you said something about all except
for six districts so as I said we um the
system is meant so that you can use it
as to develop the IEP and we will print
out the IEP in pieces like that there
are six districts that don't don't take
advantage of that they you they put in
the data that is supposed to be in there
but they don't use it as their IEP
system they use another system to write
the IEP and then they put the data into
yes all of them have those pieces in
there yes we went through that question
last year um uh so then in follow up to
where representative fellows is and
going in where spillsbury were um the
Bureau of special education support here
there's a data fact sheet which we have
it's the individuals with disabilities
Education Act ID Part B indicator five
which is that material that you are
required to submit this is time in
certain category is time served by
special education is this
required of all the districts and is it
also required from the Department of
Education on the federal level thank you
for the question um yes so this is
indicator five and there are 18
indicators that we must report to the
federal government annually um and this
is just one of them we collect all of
this for this indicator specifically we
collect this data from the special
education information system because it
ties to that placement and that Services
page so it tells us how much they
because they have to choose a setting so
they may choose a regular education
setting or they may choose a special
education setting so then that tells us
how tells us these categories that are
listed here on the data fact sheet and I
I'll just follow quickly because I I
need this answer we represent Ames just
mentioned well a kid could have all
these IEP categories and be in and we
put it down underneath this category but
is the purpose behind the federal
government asking for this information
from you and you from the
schools is is it related directly to
costing of special education for certain
students it's Rel um their request of
this is to ensure that the students are
in the least restrictive environment um
available to them so that it's
calculating um it calculates how many
students are in the regular education
classroom how many students are in a
special education classroom and it's and
it makes us aware of their least
restrictive environment are are you
putting students in a more restrictive
environment or are you putting are you
or is it not are you putting them in a
less restrictive environment least
restrictive environment is really fuzzy
term for me and I was in the business of
that and I think it's misinterpreted in
many places least restrictive
environment I want my kid in the
classroom all day long it's least
restrictive environment more aligned
with
the objectives and the goals of the
individual
IEP that should
dictate you know the other social
experience I understand and in support
and recognize but on the other side in
the academics this least restrictive
environment May hinder a child from
really gaining the education they need
to receive correct and it and it is
specific to each child you're providing
them with the least restrictive
environment for the dis their disability
and the needs that they have so each of
it should be IND idual eyes to each
child to ensure that they're in the
least restrictive environment based on
the knowledge you have of the child
thank you go back to questions from the
group I think represent Damon and then
rep simple I may have Miss wait repr
Damon first then
you really simple the numbers you gave
us for total enrollment does that
include charter school students or not
yes thank you that would include public
districts public Charters and uh the
cies um so pres Mountain so it's all all
public en yes y represent Myan I'm sorry
I interrupted um is is there any reason
why ADHD is not included on this list of
disabilities so ADHD would fall under
the other health impairment category so
it is it is but it's not been sort of
like it's not a it's not a it's not one
of the categories provided to us by the
federal government but it is recognized
under the other health impairment
category can I have one one more
question I just have one other question
with the database that you guys is it
actually possible to look at the cost
per student and and make an estimate for
the districts so um the only cost that
we currently have in the system are the
costs that they submit for special
education Aid we do not have we do not
keep track of um costs in general we
only keep track of what they submit to
us so that they can ask for special
year yes represent bricky so uh um so we
collect indicator 5 we collect that
information on indicator 5 so by
District so we would know if we we would
know in terms of C cost um indicator 5A
would probably be less than 5B less than
5 C on average so if we were looking to
tier it could we
then use these
indicators that is in one of the bills
uh it's just then how much do you cost
those tiers out as is the issue is it
within differentiated Aid and it's under
the indicator 58 I'm sorry
I so we it's not this bill though okay
yeah so we do collect that data actually
at the student level so we have to
report how many students are in each of
these categories so I could tell you
Sally Smith H is in such and such a
category but we then we disagre it to to
district and then State okay
thanks there was a sheet that you
from which which that that sheet was
used when we were trying to come up with
this in a previous year so it's dated by
year but it's very similar to what it is
now it breaks down the number of
students in C a b and c it's it's a
information where are the questions
right now represent
luno thanks very much Mr chair so um so
you you just brought up um special
education Aid what do what did districts
provide um the department uh in order to
um put in their requests for sure so
during the year um they have to put in
invoices into the system and then tell
us um and and tell us what services it
was for so if the student received
speech and language Services they they
put that in and then they they say that
they they put a sorry they give us a um
a invoice for those services and then
when we get those so they put all those
in and we keep track until and the
system will tell us when they get to cap
so right now it's three and a half time
so once it gets to cap then beyond that
it will we we know these 10 students it
says they have reached cap but in July
through December we take all of those
invoices and then we compare them to the
students IEP and we say you provided
them three speech units each week but in
their IEP it only says they receive two
speech units so we correlate that and
say well then we're only going to pay
you for the two speech units because
that's when then it's in their IEP but
they do have to provide us with the
actual invoice that they paid for that
service that correlates to the the
students IEP okay and so just to make
sure I under I I heard what you said y
um it's a it's an invoice for service
connected to a student so with a assd or
something like that and and then and
that's that's entered in at the at the
department and then the the district can
enters that in say that again the
district ENT the district entri enters
that in to to the system yeah to your
system and and uh and then and then and
then the department Compares all of
these against the IEP to make sure that
that these were all you know Services
consistent with with the IEP and is
there is there any does I guess does the
department critique the IEP at all or
critique a cost for a for a service for
and and I'm just saying for example for
example the um the department of U New
Hampshire's insurance department keeps
uh keeps track of all the cost of all
procedures
and and it can calculate the average
cost of all procedures and that database
is used by insurance carriers to you
know when they negotiate you know you
know with with service providers and
things like that so so would you does
the department also know what the cost
procedures for procedure is and what the
average cost and what the extremes are
stuff like that so we wouldn't um we
have the data we have not disaggregated
it to be able to tell you um the
different pieces um we do look at look
at everything and make sure that it's
allowable so while we also say does it
correlate to two Services three services
we also um ensure that this is something
that you can pay for with your federal
Ida funds or your state funds and it
meets federal and state regulations if
you put something in there that um you
know we're going to pay for you know a
bike trip across the United States we'd
be like that's that's not an allowable
expense that's great that you wanted to
put it in the students IEP you're trying
to support them but it's not an
allowable expense so we ALS so while we
ALS make sure that it align the IEP we
also make sure that it's an allowable
expense does that answer your question
okay thank I thought you're going to go
further with that if I may yeah actually
I I was I didn't the cost per
service may be in his district or her
District very very different yes does
the cost per service do you give any
information out to them where say you're
this is too expensive for delivery of
speech two times a week or whatever it
might be uh do you have anything that
this is what we you know see as maybe an
average cost or are we having to deliver
these services in colbrook at a higher
cost than we are in
Rochester so while I will tell you we
notice that there is a large difference
between some costs we do not currently
um disaggregate that data and and then
report to districts this is higher than
what you should be paying or what lower
than what you should be paying
so we do not currently do that so
where's the oversight come then to
determine whether this is an appropriate
cost that you're being asked to
reimburse this for so it goes back to is
it allowable and is it um it does it
align to the IEP is it an allowable
expense according to Ida is this
something that you can provide to the
child and then does it align to the IEP
but we don't have anything where we say
the cost is too high or too low or we
don't and we don't average the cost we
don't do any of that so so Mr chair yes
yeah him first and then you yeah so
thanks for that was the the question
that that I think made a lot of sense to
ask right there and um and I it sounds
like you're you're creating a little
maybe u u uh a parking lot or or a
bucket of of potential things we want to
want to dig into but with something like
what the insurance department has I
think they call it the claims data base
would that be something that that could
be useful for for the Department um down
the road in terms of being able to to
look at how these costs are and how
these services are delivered yes it
would be useful I would most likely need
more staff to be able to do that though
so y because the data is there it's just
we don't we don't have the staff or the
capacity to be able to say this is the
average cost this is the high this is
the low it's but it's let me clarify
it's only there for special education
Aid and is not there if you don't submit
Aid represent thank you um so along
these lines if a school district uh
rents a building for alternative for an
alternative program for a group of their
special education students are they
allowed to include the rental the rent
that they have to pay for that
Alternative Program classroom um and
divide it out by the number of students
that's there to submit in so an
alternative program would be a regular
education um f um placement because
alternative programs are not special
education they're under regular
education and no they would not be able
to put their rent it has to tied
directly to the services in the IEP for
the child what happens if it's King
Street King Street is a is an
alternative program with an approved
special education program within it so
they have to so so they they have an
alternative program they take any kids
in that program and then we have we have
gone in and said yes you can have
special education students within that
program can you tell me because I
believe Hillsboro Dearing is in the
alternative program and I believe they
have that running through special
education so um according to state law
they must be must submit an alternative
plan to the um the school approval
office and has to be approved by their
school board and then once they have an
alternative program we can approve a
special education program within that
alternative program but alternative
programs don't live in my office they're
not just for special education students
one more yes so given the they've been
approved and it's been a program that
has been approved can they then take
that rent and divide it by the number of
students that are in that program for
that location no because it doesn't tie
back to the services that are in the
students IEP thank
you represent representa am and
representative
Fells or is yours tied to this or which
is the better go
first pardon
me I can't hear it I can't hear you it's
a tiny question I just wanted to to know
so we know that the cost related to
students that are not going to apply for
special education Aid are generally not
in there but do do we have things that
say like speech speech and language
pathology for two hours a week do we
have all the the services are in there
for all of the all of the speci all the
services for all
32,000 kids are in in the system
representes
yeah um this is about the costs
disapproved because they're not in the
IEP um can you give us a sense of the
magnit relative magnitude of uh the
disapprovals you know relative to the
total it's asked
for I I don't have the chart in front of
me but it it's it is small it's not I
would say that it's a very small
percentage of the the what we approve
and what we provide to to um to the
districts it was in the presentation
that I had done for um um the
legislature at the department and I
could try to pull that up at some point
for you but I don't have the numbers
right in front of me right now but it is
percentage can I follow up to represent
Ames repres Ames if I'm in a district
that's a rural district and I cannot
find a speech
pathologist and and the only place I can
find one is a contracted service out of
conquer is the transportation for that
person to get to and from my school
district part of the reimbursement that
they're going to get if it's going to
add up into this special education Aid
category it would the only and I'll go
back to if if it's not in the students
IEP then it's not paid for we will only
pay for the speech and language services
that are provided to the child which are
from a person which we can hire in
conquered years ago you used to
reimburse us for that you're not doing
that anymore we will only reimburse you
for something that is tied to the
child's
IEP would the
transort but you're not so let me
clarify are you talking about the
transportation for the speech
pathologist or the transportation for
the student the the charge I'm going to
get from the speech well the child's
going to stay at school right so there's
no Transportation there other than what
we provide by the school bus to and
throw in the morning or afternoon it's
for that therapist the one with the the
Seas to come up to wherever you're
going it's just the what's in the
IEP so what if the contracted service is
building that cost in are you going to
approve that on the invoice we send you
for reimbursement if they've built it in
um it would say that the unit this unit
cost $150 for the unit they may have
built in the transportation cost but we
wouldn't pay for it separately it would
have to be part of the cost that's
I I'm I'm a little bit lost here on this
because I heard I heard dick or
represent Ames over here just mentioned
so it's got to be in the I AP but how do
you know it's going to be in the IP when
you're writing this at the IP meeting
you're you're you're saying this child
needs Speech Pathology yep where you get
it you might get it online from
California uh so I'm concerned that you
know it's it's a cost which the school
district ends up having a cough up for
the
service uh if it gets into this well for
reimbursement and Cat Aid
it's I I don't know if you have an
answer for that
but the IEP is not supposed to be based
on how much it's going to cost it's
supposed to be based on the students
needs and so that IEP team is looking at
what does this child need they need
speech path Speech Pathology and then
the district has to determine how
they're going to get that speech
pathology so you wouldn't discuss those
financial pieces within that IEP team
meeting and yes it we are finding that
districts are paying for somebody to
come from conquered to to come north or
paying for different things because they
are having difficulty finding that but
that's not a discussion that you have in
the IEP meeting because you're just
determining they need this many speech
units well when I have an i AP meeting
and I'm Des deciding this child needs a
48 week delivery of services I'm going
into the summer months so that means
there's going to have to be labor for
for that program mhm and the and the
district has to pay for that
MH I don't understand why they wouldn't
pay for the transportation then from
conquered up to you know as part of this
program
I it doesn't connect with me Mr chairman
yes so I would guess if you're a speech
pathologist in conquered and you're
giving somebody an hour's worth of
treatment that you charge say $100 right
but if you're if the treatment is in
Plymouth and and I have and the
pathologist has to drive then they would
say okay that's $200 you see what I mean
and the bill would be for $200 and they
would pay the $200 right so it' be built
into the bill of the person of the
provider who's traveling probably it
just made my case that there the the
reimbursement for that particular
service is going to be different from
District to diff District absolutely yes
and we're not doing that we're not no
well we're paying it yes we're not
tracking it but we are paying it yeah
yeah M Mr chair just on on that exact
same line though if the if the if the
bill for service from the speech
pathologist contained two line items
Speech Pathology you know one hour
session with the with the student uh and
then line two Transportation one hour
for a total of $200 you know $100 each
line would you pay the would you would
you approve the $200 or would you
exclude the um the line two if it's
listed separately from the hourly rate
for the Speech Pathology it would not be
paid it would only be paid for this for
the Speech Pathology you know I'm going
to take a I'm take a second here there's
a prior director here that this is her
thing Becky can you please give us a
little information from your perspective
working yeah two Becky out there
good morning for the whoa that is right
in my face wow uh good morning for the
record Becky Wilson from the New
Hampshire school boards Association I
appreciate the opportunity to come up uh
for anyone who does not know me prior to
my work at the school boards Association
I was a special ed director here in the
state for about 20 years I think to try
to clarify some of these questions
around the speech and language cost
specifically or other related Services
the school as Miss fet said the IEP team
is supposed to make decisions based on
the student without to some extent
consideration for the financial impact
to the district that is the base of
creating an IEP that is individualized
for
students the district then as Miss fet
said has to figure out how to provide
those Services where to provide them Etc
if the district cannot doesn't have a
district employee for example like a
speech and language pathologist I'll
stick with that example because it's
very accurate and
the district has to seek out somebody to
provide those services that meets the
qualifications that are needed for that
service that may mean that the district
has a contract with an outside provider
which I think is what many of you are
talking about that is a contract that is
between the school district the school
board and the provider those contracts
look very different depending on the
types of Provider if it is a tella
health model or a person that's driving
from you know a different state or a
different town to come to provide those
services the only services that the
department is counting towards the cap
for special education aid for example
are the is the hourly rate for that
person for example that is providing
whatever is in that student's IEP some
contracts between districts may say
we're going to roll all of this Contra
contracted provids costs into an hourly
rate and that's the hourly rate some
contracts have travel expenses separated
out from their hourly rate for Direct
Services it just depends on the contract
but the only thing the district is
getting to count towards the cap is the
Direct Services that are called out in
IEP yes yes represent
Damon
yeah all of you so then Can a
district uh
ethically say to a contracted provider
who is billing for their services with
transportation build
separately can they say if you put this
as one bundled rate we will get better
reimbursement thank you for the question
representative the provider didn't
figure it out themselves
I there are lots of different providers
currently for related services that
includes OT PT nursing speech and
language Transportation all kinds of
contracts that your districts are trying
to coordinate I don't
know many contracted providers whose um
primary goal is to ensure that districts
are getting the best reimbursement rate
Aid one more yes thank you and for any
of you what happens if a district simply
cannot find a provider contracted or in
house to provide a service that is
needed and is in the child's EP thank
you for the question
um the district is obligated to provide
that service there are times where that
is just not something that can happen in
that moment because maybe there are not
providers exam for example uh the
district would then be responsible for
compensatory Services down the road when
they can find those or to somehow work
with the family to figure out a way to
reimburse the family to go get those
Services if there was some other way to
do that that's an agreement between the
district and the family about how those
services are going to be provided at
some point they are on the hook for
regardless okay I'm going to go to
representative papovich over there then
then I'm going to try to start shifting
us to a little bit more on the special
education a yes and this is just a
clarification question thank you Mr
chairman and again thank you for for
being here I just want to confirm that I
understood correctly that when we are
talking about the actual cost of
services
assuming that there is an itemized
invoice the department would only
consider the actual cost of services to
be allowable while if the same provider
would choose to Bill to include their
travel costs into their hourly rate per
Services then that would lead to the
department having to consider that
allowable because they don't necessarily
know that it includes travel costs I
just want to make sure I understand the
status quo yes that is correct because
we do not have the contract that they
may have may have made with that service
provider so if they made a contract with
a speech pathologist and they said we're
going to put it all into that hourly
rate we don't have that contract to be
able to look at that but the in we only
get the invoice that shows us what um
what what was paid for thank you so much
okay one question here and then we will
move in a different direction or similar
Direction similar so thank you thank you
uh
so this is sort of for both of you um or
all three of you um if you couldn't get
if the district couldn't get services
and they had to reimburse the family
would that count would you would the
state then reimburse the district for
reimbursing the family if they had the
documentation of it it would definitely
be several conversations and um
providing documentation so that we could
say yes we understand why you had to do
it this way um and then we would yes
reimburse them but it would it wouldn't
just be oh yeah yeah we'll do that it
would be would be several conversations
and then some docu lots of documentation
to show why it was like that thank you I
also just want to clarify that when
we're talking about reimbursing the
district all that the costs that are
being confirmed by the department are
really to try to look at whether or not
that particular case meets the cap for
special ed Aid it's not about
reimbursing for Individual Services it's
about what number you're putting into
the pot to see what whether or not the
case hits the cap of the three and a
half or the 10
times so the service that you're looking
at you know let's say it's an $80,000
cost to the district well you're going
to pay the $770,000 then you take the
remaining 10 and take 20% of that that
you're accountable for and the rest so
basically it's all being coughed up by
the local
right the next thing which I'd like to
do though Brian Eaton is here with us uh
he's an analyst with them over there in
the department did I hand this sheet out
to people prior to it's not in that
packet I don't know if I hand it out at
another
meeting yesterday any anybody that
here why you for those that don't for
those don't have a copy why don't you
just take one of these that's coming
around
around there is another sheet which you
have there there and it's it's a it's a
very
incomplete just like you know very very
incomplete um and it basically says
count of school year 2024 for students
eligible for special education Aid and
the numbers which we requested these are
the the
municipalities this this sheet looks
this and you can see there's two
100K so that would be the bracket in
which you know the the the state would
help do some supporting because we've
gone over the 70,000 threshold is that
correct
Brian I'm sorry could you repeat the
question okay the you on on this sheet
you have all those categories by
$100,000 correct brackets on this sheet
right here I don't know if you have this
right there with you this only takes
care of two of those brackets right
there from 0 to 100 and 100 to 200 and
list the number of kids qualifying in
each of those
brackets I'm assuming that when the one
that's a 0 to
100K that's after the local district has
paid off everything there responsible
for the $70,000 three and a half times
these costs are the total cost submitted
to the department for sped Aid so it
include all the costs that they're
reimbursement yeah and so of that zero
to 100 then the locals going to be
paying $770,000 of that correct yeah
yeah exactly okay so there's only
$30,000 there then that okay so we know
then that there's a number of kids in
that first bracket from Bedford for
example there's 33 kids that that's what
we were
given how much how much of that then is
local how much of that is
state it might vary by student because
they might have different costs so we
could break that down further but just
showing here wouldn't tell you that
answer unfortunately just looking at
this year I think we're getting into a
question representa F has on that do you
have anything on that it's breaking this
pupil so what the department said they
could provide to me in time to us is the
other chart you have that you were
showing on earlier that that's pretty
much blank because
they consolidation of that so this one
you understand that they cannot report
numbers that are 10 or fewer does
everybody get that so these blanks
doesn't mean zero it means 10 or fewer
they didn't get that sheet I just
Consolidated all because all the others
are zeros but this is true of this one
too that you handed out yeah yeah yeah
okay so what they said they could get
for me is a yeah so so the blanks in
there does not mean zero it means
somewhere between Z and 10 okay so the
the state has provided this same
document for every District looks a lot
like this except with a lot more zeros
in it a lot more blanks in it and it's
not very useful what they did say they
can provide which they're going to
provide is instead of blanks and instead
of Counting kids putting in the total
dollar amount per district and I think
that's what we're trying to get to here
if I'm not mistaken yeah that's exactly
right okay I had finished that yesterday
afternoon and send it to our
commissioner it must have not made it
through the chain in time I do have it
on my screen here that's not any help to
you right now but um you can email it I
could yeah y we could definitely push it
through the chain U the our commissioner
um so that's for all the school
districts yes yes I have it by for
special education Aid and it goes up
beyond the just these two categories
goes to all the categories correct every
student accounted for additionally on
the right I have total enrollment for
that District as well as total special
education enrollment to put it into
perspective as well again also um
redacting anything less than 10 so okay
representa papovich thank you just a
very quick clarification questions at
the very beginning you said that this
include all the cost submitted to the
department I want understand if you are
referring to all cost submitted or to
all cost submitted and deemed valid
deemed valid yes deemed valid thank
you represent Luna thanks very much so
so we're still talking about um special
education Aid so the formerly
catastrophic Aid so in the obviously in
in in the current budget that that we're
in the
2425 uh budget um in for FY 25 the the
the appropriated amount came up $17
million short I mean I think that's 34
to 51 point something right well went
from about 16 almost 17 say 17 yeah yeah
yeah so so so I guess um a couple
questions here what was what what was
the source of the estimate uh for the
appropriate for the FY 24 and fy2 uh
budget Appropriations what was the
source for that estimate and was that
estimate sufficient for the claims
submitted by school districts for fy2 24
because I don't recall us having this
same conversation a year ago it seemed
to be I think that conversation's ever
come to the education committee no but
I'm just like I don't think it was a
problem last year I well it has been in
previous year so it went back to 2013
the pration amount was very equal to
what we're having this year around
67% so last year the pration was in the
80 80s okay and we we have prated um and
like I said that presentation I gave to
the legislature it is in there but we
have prated since um the since the
pandemic and then we went all the way
back to I think 20
2017 and that was the last time we were
at 100% um so it's been pro-rated sorry
so I guess the question is what what was
2022 well that during the pandemic we
were at 100% but I think it goes back to
20 2013 that was the last time we were
at 100% every year has been PR rated at
some percent this is the lowest we've
been in several years that's why it was
such an impact okay so so the yeah so so
it goes back to that that first qu that
primary question what was the source of
the estimate used for the uh the the FY
24 fy2 budget
appropriation I did not do the
appropriation so I would have to find
that out for
you I I think that would be helpful well
it's been an issue because in 2013 fy13
we had an we were short like we are now
uh then it
improved uh with there's been ups and
downs uh but it's this is significant
this is uh a human cry coming out of the
school district right now uh having to
look back and say how do we do this um
and how can we more accurately uh
appropriate the necessary dollars in our
forecast for the you
know so so would it would it be helpful
also to get a I mean similar to the the
the chart you've got here 2000 through
2023 uh like a pration um I have that
and that y would that be helpful Mr yeah
I think that's have that that would be a
good question further questions
regarding the the special education Aid
here yes rson
Damon thank you so on the page listing
students the complete one as it was
described what is the
number in the
second
horizontal uh where it says Z to 100K
dot dot do 289 and then 100 to 200k dot
dot dot 492 what's the 289 and the 492 I
don't
understand
yeah that seems very unlikely total
number of students so I am so that's the
total number of students in that
category there's only 289 across the
entire state in Z to 100,000 I did you
did create this that doesn't seem
credible sorry if that's the case it
doesn't balance with it doesn't balance
with this chart if that's the case
CU this chart says
275 sorry one second just pulling up
you well the the numbers are very close
here there's some moving Parts obviously
because if you look at that second
category here it says 492 there it says
495 right well for Budget purposes we're
certainly in the ballpark right um and
same thing with the other which going
from 289 to 275 it's yeah that's correct
so I just double checked so it just
doesn't show the full uh all the
brackets but yes that is correct that
there were 289 students uh submitting
for reimbursing through special
education Aid in the 0 to 100,000 uh
cost category and so forth for 492 to
the other bracket it what up to the 800
800 count figure there's only 800
students in special education Aid so
that that's how that works out there's
four other categories that are on this
paper
got it thank you uh represent Maguire
thank you Mr chairman is it possible the
difference between 289 and 280 275 one
is the number that submitted and one is
the number that were actually eligible
because they reached the
$7,000
threshold sorry could you repeat that
well you said that 289 was the number
that submitted right but it's possible
that 275 was the actual number that
turned out to be eligible because a few
of them submitted but they didn't they
didn't reach the threshold of $70,000
right this
is right they're eligible because they
reached that threshold you see what I
mean we're not sure where 275 figures
from which which one I referen it for
that okay oh so that's a good point
Thank you for pointing that out so uh
when I had broken down by District um
there are students that are dual
District that so this C so there this um
chart here uh this one does have a su
duplication it's not many it's I think
it's a dozen or so students that do
claim for two different districts split
District services so there are there
might be a student uh that's in one
District as well as another County in
both those they moved during the school
year and so that's why they would be in
two different districts gotcha may I
follow up yes so so a couple of towns
here sort of jump off the chart
specifically Derry and over as compared
to Manchester right VAR and over what
are they have a third the size of
population compared to Manchester and
yet they have as many or more in these
categories than Manchester does so
wouldn't that tell you that
maybe they need more instruction or
whatever in terms of how they're coding
people because they're somehow overdoing
it
I think the numbers are more correlate
to um if they've kept track of the
student cost and then submitted to us
for special education Aid so there may
be that they they are doing very well at
tracking students and very well at
applying for special education Aid and
they that would I would attribute it to
that because it is we don't determine
which students get submitted for special
education Aid it is up to the district
to determine who they're going to submit
to us for special education Aid they can
decide that we're only going to put in
um invoices for these you know 16
students and they don't put in for
anybody else I follow yes so I would
think the districts are are very
unlikely to leave money on the table you
know what I mean so that if somebody
qualifies is close to $70,000 or more
they would know it and they would they
would submit as much as they can for
them right I would hope so yes and I
would assume Manchester in particular
does that pretty well because they're so
large right they must have a lot of
employees that do this kind of thing and
and that sort of thing so I would think
Manchester would be sort of the average
and would would kind
of you know do you see what I mean and
so and there's clearly differences right
there's clearly some areas that have way
higher populations of special ed in
these high categories than others and
and you you know you could think it's
Maybe random but
you know they're just so much higher
that you think maybe it's a choice right
it's a it's a decision they're making
kind of and that would go back to we
need to be able to analyze the data to
determine you know are you outplaced
than you know what's your percentage of
it goes back to representative poic's
question about analyzing the data and
determining you know where that money is
going so we I would not be able to give
you that answer to tell you if you know
if they are if they are out placing
students in um residential or um outof
District facilities which is typically
where the high costs come from more
frequently than other
districts may I ask one more just go
ahead and follow it up then
representative bricky but I I want to
follow up one thing then we'll go
representative bricky and then did you
have your end up so for such districts
like like the ones we pointed out here
if we gave you more
employees could you do some auditing
could you have someone sort of go to
those District s look at specific
IEPs and and think and and and and look
at the data on those students and and
see whether they sort of fall in line
with General accepted practice because
I'm assuming you don't do any of that
right you're looking in detail I got a I
got an invoice I got an i AP they match
good right but you're not really looking
at how the IEP was was created in the
first place right so while
thank you for the question while I can
look at um I I can't question the
determination of an IEP team to place a
child but I can look at the broader
picture of what percentage of students
are you placing in an a of District
placement or or pieces like that but I
I'm I can't question the determination
of an IEP team they have made that
decision I can't go against that I can't
say no your decision was wrong um but we
can look at it and say you're you're
you're outplacement more frequently than
other districts your percentage is
higher um and and we could do that and
we wouldn't even have to go to districts
because we would be able to look at
those IEPs in the special education
information system but I would need
people to do
that and just quickly and then we'll go
to represent bricky then represent L
um we at least in my experience in
education there are what we call magnet
schools school districts which have a
wonderful special education program or
have the
the the wherewithal to provide these
Services whereas District over here
doesn't and we have a high movement of
students naturally we're a moving
society and you don't know what's coming
at you we also have though these schools
which have these services so sometimes
parents will look not sometimes quite
often they'll look where is my child
going to get those services so is that
does that contribute
to certain districts having higher cost
of this and with that contribution Is it
wise for us to be allocating dollars in
on an average to all districts or to
look more closely at those districts
which have this higher number of
students qualifying for this type of
service so that we don't have to start
providing those Services which are
provided there necessarily or maybe we
can do it through some transportation of
services to a small school district that
may only have 80 kids in that district
and we have some like that in fact I'm
talking about one Pont had two of these
kids move in in one year all those both
those kids were well over $20 something
thousand a piece totally
unplanned uh how do we Rectify that type
of situation from
occurring I I don't think you can
Rectify that situation I think that yes
there are times that districts have a um
that people will move to a district
because it's a good school system or
they know hear that special education is
done well there but I that you can't
predict that I can't predict I I I can't
predict that two people be allocating
our resources though to those districts
which have a higher higher number of
kids needing that type of service from
our from our history that we
see rather than saying well we're going
to fund X number dollars to every
student or you know to every district
for in our differentiated Aid
category um differentiated Aid sorry I
thought we were talking about special
going back and forth here because the
money's got to come from somewhere
supposedly and I know that's not
directed to special education I
understand the reasons why we have
$2,100 you know we've got to help out
these districts at that all districts
somehow with our with those costs I
think it's I I think it's a
determination that you as a committee
need to make I I yeah I think that we
need to you can look at the how much is
being spent on each child you can look
at you know those categories um I will
tell you that if you do look at those
categories on our end federally we need
to have policies and procedures that
ensure that um fape is not being uh it
was a concern that was brought up
yesterday in the conversations that fape
is not being um hindered and that
students aren't being placed in more
restrictive environments just so they
can get that extra funding so um I I
think it does we do need to look at it
more clearly but it's hard to say
whether you should do by category or if
you need to look at cost it any of those
are going
to be helpful represent bricky you had
your hand
up it goes back to
um the question about the disparity
between the numbers in the columns could
it also be because these are only the
first
two categories and we're missing the top
four categories so these are the those
are the largest just two categories the
other categories have much smaller
numbers right they are I mean I can see
that here on this chart but do you do
you think that like the question was
about the disparity between um what was
it Manchester
and I don't recall now Derry and Derry
and um do you think that that's the the
reason that it looks like the way that
it does they those districts may have
more in the upper categories then in the
lower categories or anything I would be
speculation I I I can't say see that n
number 10 or less or less we're using
when you're looking at four and 10
students on the top two categories there
we're not going to get that information
no and we shouldn't yeah um no it was uh
je was just going around represent luno
yes yes I knew there was somebody there
thanks very much Mr chair um so when
when when you take a look at these um
these these these costs by students and
in these in these fairly High you know
100,000 you know
categories um are there are there any
sort of um trend's not the right number
but are there you know is there any um
um you know any information like by you
know how old the student is like are
there would there be more um 18y olds in
high cost situations than eight-year
olds or anything like that I don't they
don't necess I wouldn't say they
necessarily correlate to age but they
would correlate to um where they're
receiving their services typically um if
a student is out of District in a
private provider in New Hampshire or out
of state that's when those costs are
going to hit those higher numbers it's
not typically by age okay so so the
incidence of these high cost situations
would would are sort probably spread
fairly evenly across AG across all the
age groups I I would say so yeah so so
the the and the reason I asked that is
is I think just just a few years ago we
um we we changed the we increased the um
the
the the the age range of when when
school districts have to provide
services to students from 21 to
22 and and and the word inclusive was
used too so I don't know if if if if
that is aged 20 as soon as they turn 22
they they that that districts
discontinue or as soon as they're 22 and
the end of the school year coincides or
when they turn 23 I'm not sure but did
any of that contribute to the um you
know what we've seen in the the numbers
so it um the the language is 21
inclusive so it goes up to their 22nd
birthday and then um districts are not
required to provide services from once
they turn 22 some districts do they'll
let them go out the rest of the year but
um typically it ends at their 20 just
the day before their 22nd birthday we
did put out um and Brian has the number
so I'm gonna let Brian talk to you sure
thank you for the question U so that's a
question that we definitely wanted to
try and answer uh I think it was
November December I believe and that
there was a press release on it uh so
what I had looked at was the count of
students in special education Aid being
submitted as well as the average cost I
saw that both of them increased and I
looked at that back
to 2017 and it kind of fluctuated back
and forth whether it was more students
being submitted or the average cost was
increasing so it was it's been very
variable since 2017 but for 2024 we did
see that there was um the cost was
attributed to both average cost
increasing and the amount of students
being increased than previously and the
amount of students because of the the
the the 22 I I thought my head it wasn't
um it wasn't major from the from the
additional age uh being included it was
across the board but I can look back and
get more specific on that okay before we
go with some other questions right now
um if if we need questions re uh
reference these stats right here
statistics here but what we need to do
is get down a little bit what would
happen if we start reducing the
responsibility of the local from 3 and
A2 to three to 2 and 1/2 to whatever uh
represents SP he does have a question
regard that sort of refocuses a little
bit and go in a direction some of these
bills which we have in front of us so
are there any more questions on where we
are right now before he tries to
redirect the conversation in that
direction uh represent Burton and and
just a quick quick observation the
Oyster River is a magnet we spend $8
million on special ed and we get 150,000
us represent papovich thank you Mr thank
you well thank you Mr chair and again
thank you for being here it's a
clarification question on something that
remark from the chairman brought up we
have these students that are at the far
out end of the level of services they
need and we have that call it a 70k more
or less cap what happens to a student
who is uh you know costing whose support
will be 100,000 a year that moves in
halfway through the school year from one
District to another each district
reaches 50k so does that mean that
neither District reaches the cap even
though the student was above the cap as
a student but it was split between
different schools we would take that
into thank you for the question we would
take that into consideration and the
calc and we determin how long the child
was in each of the districts and so how
much cap each of the districts would
need to pay based on how long the child
was in so you would look at the student
as a whole notice that they exceed the
cap and then a portion whatever
reimbursement based on you know your
best estimate of how it's appropriate
yes thank you that's one thing we'll one
last thing we need to fix I appreciate
it thank
you represent PHS one and then in
represent spillsbury so I would wonder
if you can use your database to tell us
where those high cost students are are
going if there are any places in the
state that they're that they're going
that um maybe we could look at those
programs for particularly a district
that's sending those kids to um another
district for some kind of program so we
can see if there's any cost efficiency
there that we could support somehow so
in my presentation to the legislature
where the prime and it was a very rough
estimate I will clarify that again where
most of the costs were were in our New
Hampshire private providers of special
education those are approved programs
that we approve and we set their rates
so they don't um randomly set rates it
is it's a rate they submit for each year
and we analyze their costs and provide
them with a rate each year the cost that
we don't have control over would be if
the student went out of state um and
they went to a a provider out of state
we wouldn't be able to control that but
any of those approved providers in New
Hampshire um we do approve that rate for
them does that include another school
district no it does
not represent spillsbury
thank you Mr chair um I just want to
make sure a couple of these uh data
points correct before I POS the question
so in the chart that we have in front of
us the uh the lowcost high census
category of 0 to 100 I see on the next
page in another chart that same group of
200 that same cohort of
275 uh individuals is labeled as 50 to
100 uh so in my mind I'm already
relabeling chart one is 5050 to 100
right they're all they're all contained
within that upper
half and and I assume in fact that
they're virtually all really 70 to
100 right they wouldn't be submitted for
special education s until they so really
what we're measuring here is anybody
who's eligible based on having exceeded
the cost of three and a half times the
okay correct so I'm just going to
now
um as we bring the threshold down
hypothetically um we're going to be
looking at lower costs per student but
we're going to have an increasing Census
count at each lower threshold I think
that's very hard for us to uh project
and I'm wondering whether you could
model what it would look like for the
state in terms of cost per student total
number of students total cost of the
state at each um half multiplier
threshold in other words taking it down
assum the average student is 20 the
threshold is 70 where would we be at
three times two and a half times two
times one and a half times can we do
that that would be a very valuable thing
I think for the next time we get
together on this
subject so data wise we would not have
the data for anybody that is below 30
below the cap below that 70,000 we would
not have them because they don't submit
to us for it so if they know they're if
they have a student that is not going to
meet cap we don't have that data so you
have other data that you can interpolate
from thank you for the question I don't
believe we have any data that wouldn't
be that would be able to be addition in
addition to what's in sped Aid the only
other U metric we could pull is from the
due2 the annual financial report
District submit and base that off of uh
the amount of services that or the
amount of students that receive Services
by that District but we haven't done
that analysis ourselves we're not sure
how how complete would be able to be
done so I can't think of another way we
could estimate the amount of students
that would be in those half multipliers
based on the data that we have
unfortunately that's that's quite a
conundrum for us as makers that is a
real conundrum uh seeing that there are
states that are we know of one state
$115,000 and then from 15 to
65 the spa the state then pays that
amount from 15 to 65 from 65 on onwards
to get into formula similar to what we
have when we get three and a half to 10
times so how are we going to be able
to help on this situation if we are
unable to identify what those numbers
you know if we just point blank pick a
number let's say we pick 15,000 like
that other state does
um how are we going to transition to a
that the only data that we could look at
is that those students that were
submitted for special education Aid and
tell you the impact based on just those
students so we had
800 students we could say if the cap
went down how much it would have
increased for those 800 students but we
they we just don't have the other data
you don't have invoices you know you
have invoices to come to you right for
if identified this the district has
appropriately spent this $70,000 but
they need this additional and so they're
now they're getting into special
education Aid so don't we have some kind
of uh material from the the the local
districts on these
children of their cost of the program
they're currently providing that they're
not getting any reur from the state on
specifically just sped Aid submitting
reim submitting
invoices I can't think of anything that
we would but we can follow up definitely
I can't think of anything on top my head
that we have additional data on in terms
of costs per special education student
except if you were to take the total um
special education expenditures from the
du2 and divide how we got to the 29,000
average uh cost per special education
student um but you can't drill we don't
have any we don't have any more
additional drill down information to to
the student level just by District or by
you so okay further questions represent
Damon just want to make sure I
understand what you've just um
acknowledged so if the student has an
IEP and the cost of providing the
services in the I is less than
$70,000 they're not submitting any data
to you and so we can't track how many
kids are at 60 to 70,000 or 50 to 70
correct correct the only data that they
would submit is on the doe 25 how much
they spent on spent on special education
but we do not collect invoices or any
data within the special education
information system if because they don't
submit it to us if they're not
submitting for special education
Aid well F and on the
doe2 that is not a per student number
that is a district number I agree thank
you further question repres
luno so of the data that that that you
have collected through these through the
the the special education Aid um app you
know data collection are
there is there is there any sort of you
know trend line of um of of of spending
that creates some sort of curve that
that you might be able to um to
project what you know what spending
might be or what cost might be like at
some of these levels below three and a
half um and I guess this question myself
for Becky um unless there's students
unless there's invoices that are
submitted into nessus for students who
don't make it to that 70,000 cap is that
the case I think but let me just clarify
I think what you're asking is with the
data we do have which is the 800 some
odd students you're asking if there's a
trend line within what they spent their
funding on per child and the number of
students and the number of students if
we would be able to figure out and he's
the money person I'm just interpreting
what you said um if we would be able to
figure out kind of a trend of what it
might look like with more students it's
a it's a it's a projection as an as an
estimate so absent absent any data
absent any data in that range um can we
take the data we do have and somehow and
somehow develop a a best guas projection
we can certainly try uh I will go back
to my to my team and see what we can
come up with off top of my head I'm not
too sure sure I can't speak to that but
we can definitely that's that's a very
high priority that's something that we
would definitely try to move towards
yeah I mean I think I think a best guest
would be helpful yeah if you could bring
that we'd provide Donuts at the next
meeting
yeah represent papovich thank you I'm
just trying to build on what the
representative luno is saying
um completely acknowledge that you guys
don't have the data for people under
70k would it be useful if you identified
maybe other states that have that data
data available and look at their
distribution in the coost Stranges
obviously it's very hard to adjust for
because they're highly Regional I'm sure
that what they do in the South or the
Northwest doesn't quite match to us but
would that at least give you an idea of
how you know those students would be
distributed in the various categories
just offering a thought if you find it
useful I couldn't tell you for a fact
that it will be useful but just
kind of brainstorming you know work
session you know so thank you yes that
is worth pursuing so thank you there's
other ways of addressing this issue if
we don't get that data you know it the
2080 ratio uh from six and a half or
from three and a half up to 10 or the
pration amount you can't prate anything
less than x number percentage
um CH
GP so yeah that's an interesting yeah
represent fellows yeah so if you're
going to dig into the data I would think
that it might be useful to separate out
transportation from other services
because we know that's a really huge
chunk of money so and from the um when I
looked at the information and just did a
cursory it was about 12% of what we paid
Aid
yes okay are there any other questions
uh at this point in time we're going to
have another work session we're just
wearing to I have a meeting I got to be
at at 12
o'clock um so we're going to have to
quit here in 15 minutes or so but is
there anything else we need to drive at
or request of information from the
Department so when we do have a next
work session on special education Aid
um yes re
bilbury I'd like to just throw out two
thoughts uh that we can all noodle on no
specific proposal today but just the
kinds of things I'm asking
myself first of all I I view this whole
Enterprise of how you gauge the way in
which and the amount in which the state
is going to support special ed education
as like an insurance policy problem
right and insurance policies are often a
complicated mix of uh um co-pay and
deductible and and in percentage of
sharing and I'm sure that was what was
the driving thought process when when
all of this was first evolving so think
like an insurance company does how do
you take all of those moving parts and
and shift them around um because it
doesn't necessarily have to follow the
construct that's in the law today there
may be better more effective ways for
the state to uh to shoulder its
burden one of the things I'm thinking
about for example is
why don't we leave
adequacy to focus on that um standard
per student base
adequacy maybe with adjustments for
poverty and and uh in the poor towns but
but not mix special education into
that and then take the special education
issue holistically on its own and ask
ourselves what if if the basis of the
cad Aid is more like an insurance policy
in the multiplier what if hypothetically
we brought that multiplier all the way
down to one and a half or two so now
you're saying okay the district has to
pay the first
20,000 uh which is what it's paying for
every student it's going to get the base
adequacy for every student regardless of
whether it's a special ed or
not but with the special ed the State
share is it 100% is it 8020 you know
does that change in categories kicks in
much
earlier so just food for thought these
are the kinds of variables I'm trying to
think and I'm not sure that uh that just
amending the several laws we have by
Shifting the numbers is really the right
way to get to the best
result thank you represent Burton yeah
when the augen committee which I was on
co-chaired um we came up with 1.5 so in
the augen bck formula the town got 1.5
of the average cost for every special ed
student and that's how we took care of
special ed now it that was
1985 but it was simple it worked and it
was applied to every single town the
same
way okay so
I want to thank
uh Becky fet and Becky Wilson and and
Brian Eaton here for coming today uh we
we're going to we've taken notes here
and we have some areas which we see
there were questions and Concepts and
elements that we want to pursue we're
going to try to synthesize it down to
that and then we'll share it with you
and then uh hopefully we can get it get
together again we we have to make some
decisions on this in in short time by by
the first week of March and so uh we
have to March and we have a number of
bills this is critical to both our
funding formula and to the special
education formula as well so thank you
very much for coming today and have a
good afternoon so
you okay
e